president biden now trying to pressure
the media into giving him better
coverage the white house is not happy
with how the press has been talking
about inflation and the supply crisis so
a group of senior officials are
reportedly holding secret meetings with
major outlets and are trying to convince
them into more coerce them i should say
into more positive coverage and it looks
like the view got the message loud and
clear
the question is why don't people want to
hear the good news for a change you know
is that what we need to to hear when
something good is happening here you
said you know that people are not
picking up on the good stuff i believe
that that's because the media is not
portraying him as a winner they are
minimizing what he is doing when the
chips are down americans are going to
understand that if republicans take
control of this country again we are
done as a country we are done
now believe it and they actually applaud
what do you say jesse that's an
enlightened crowd
what you might want to go on there i
know yeah for the next book yeah we
might have to do the view um do you
realize how bad things must be for a
democrat president to be begging
democrats in the media for a better spin
haven't they done enough judge i mean
they spiked the laptop they ignore the
border they cheerlead all of his
mandates and they write stories like why
inflation is actually a good thing yeah
i mean like what else could they do it's
like me telling johnny like johnny have
to do more you're really not doing
enough like what else could johnny do
breastfeed jesse jr honestly i mean if
he could i'd ask for it but the thing
that's going on here is this
biden has some nerve to ask the press
he doesn't even talk to the press he
turns around like he's deaf every time
he stares talking he's done two sit-down
interviews since may last time i checked
it's december what does he do he clowns
around at a town hall with lemon or
cooper the whole time he hasn't even sat
down with the ap reuters washington post
new york times wall street journal and
then he complains about bad coverage
he's not selling his agenda because he's
a poor communicator and so his team is
going to all the journalists and saying
can you be a little bit more like jen
saki try to be a little bit more like
jen and if he had good results those
results would sell themselves if he was
reducing crime inflation illegal
immigration but
cases
they're saying he's not communicating
properly is he not communicating
properly or is jesse right that he has
limited the number of interviews and is
continuing his campaign bunker strategy
i have to imagine that if i were those
reports those newsrooms that got one of
these visits i would say excuse me
because we haven't heard from him we
haven't even talked to him like we can
ask jen saki questions she's the press
secretary she's very available and she
answers all the questions might not like
the answers but that's what they are he
doesn't do he's not selling it and they
i i read these headlines um biden's
communicators are to blame no they're
not
and also they miss opportunities all the
time but it comes from the top for
example the other day they could have
had a great press conference and said
get well guess what omicron not as not
as lethal as we thought so this is great
news and in fact guess what you're not
going to have to wear a mask on a plane
something like that like they could make
decisions based on science actually that
would that would help them but this is
the same white house that demanded
better coverage for the amazing airlift
they did out of afghanistan it's like
people were falling off of planes this
is the white house that said that
republicans were the ones that wanted to
defund the police they had to backtrack
on that they said that inflation wasn't
happening then they said well it's just
transitory when people are basically
seeing the
in the in their own lives but also in
the statistics that come out so i i i
gotta hand it to them like to go in like
they know that they have a problem so
that they're gonna go in i don't think
that it's going to change though the
view saying we should all be happy and
celebrate the wins it's not going to
change the fact that when you're at the
grocery store and you see somebody in
front of you that basically is like
counting up the items and having to put
away the rice krispies treat ingredients
and i heard this from a democrat on the
against the grain podcast
that stuff's real it is real but but
greg what about the allegation that the
press is underselling the good news what
is the good news
it's hilarious i mean here's it this
reminds me of a guy going to another guy
and pleading with him to talk him up in
front of a girl he likes right
yeah exactly i do that you know when i
talk to the ceo at fox about jessie
jesse's really coming along but it's but
if you gotta be total
i mean think about it when the view
becomes your public relations arm yeah i
mean i guess i guess the cast from teen
mom was busy because i mean this is i
mean it's it's amazing how almost like
robotic that was but i love also how
this is posed as a secret meeting behind
the scenes is it right we it
acknowledges the fact that the biden
white house is indeed a facade like a
storefront from an episode of gunsmoke
and you just right behind that's just
fake it's all this other stuff going on
they don't know what the hell is going
on i just long for the good old days
when trump would just trump didn't do
trump would talk to anybody and
everybody he knew exactly what he was
thinking and he of course he did call he
the only people he called in the news
were commentariats right he never like
went to the heart they didn't call up
anybody didn't call up bret bear i don't
know you'd be surprised
he called everybody everyone
but everything he said on the phone he
would say on tv
joe doesn't talk to anybody except for
himself when he's muttering in the yard
yeah all right jessica now think about
it the white house has three other
senior officials trying to talk to the
press and the one that i thought was
most interesting to persuade the press
to give them better coverage was the
ports envoy yeah i guess he's going to
tell him the supply chain problem is
isn't as bad as we think it is well
ports are top of mind for people yeah
because so what's good news well the
good news i actually i thought this was
interesting today joe manchin put out
this he carries around a card of the
administration's accomplishments joe
manchin who i find to be relentlessly
negative actually in terms of democratic
causes actually walks around with this
and talks about the coveted relief act
talks to the bipartisan infrastructure
act money
people need money and they like money
and republicans love money more than
democrats do so that should be a good
thing oh this money is going well go
ahead
they clearly know there's a problem and
there were two things today that struck
my interest on this front one that joe
manchin carries around this card and two
the monmouth poll that showed that
inflation and kitchen table issues are
top of mind for basically every voter no
matter your partisan affiliation and
that's what they're having to run
against and
having a ports envoy have this
conversation or people who aren't joe
biden who i think does actually pretty
well in these interviews is not going to
hack it for the american public and so
that needs to switch around before the
midterms come around and people want to
see their president
okay ahead democrats are now turning
fast on biden's vaccine mandates hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else